welcome back everyone to my round nine
recap from bugle this was a super
interesting game I played against I am
Wong Chen from China
and coming into this game I was
expecting him to play E4 which he did
and I decided beforehand I was gonna
play a sicilian now in recent times I've
mixed up the moves that I play on move 2
in this position in previous tournaments
I've been playing Knight C6 and going
for an accelerated Dragon I've also
played D6 and gone for a dragon dwarf
which is kind of a hybrid of a dragon
and a night or
but I saw against Knight C6 and D6 my
opponent likes to play Bishop B5
so I chose to play a line that I used to
play as my main weapon against E4 is the
taimanov starting with E6
and I wasn't entirely sure what to
expect coming into this game for my
opponent over the years he's played B3
he's played C3 he's played D4 he's
played G3 so before the game I was just
trying to be ready for all the options
and he ended up playing upon to G3 which
was one of the main things I was
studying I think he's played this most
recently against polony six
and in this position I opted for a move
that I've never played before which is
Pawn to D5
and I do want to say that this opening
G3 on move 3 is something that I've
struggled with over the years I've lost
a lot of tough games from the box side
of this position and most of my previous
games have been after Knight C6
so coming into the scheme and also
coming into this tournament I knew that
I wanted to mix up my opening repertoire
from this position and D5 seems like a
nice alternative and it's a way more
confrontational move that can lead to a
lot of interesting positions now the
main line by far is takes takes and then
white has either D4 or Bishop G2 both
moves I was prepared for but after I
played D5 my opponent started thinking
and ended up playing a move that is not
so common which is Knight to C3
and I was actually very fortunate
because this morning I was just going
through my opening lines and I was
looking for any sort of surprises white
could throw at me in this position and I
had specifically checked Knight C3 and
looked into what to do and for the next
maybe five or six moves I was still
within my preparation and I basically
just blitzed out the next several moves
given that they were on my computer uh
right before the game and I quickly
played Pawn D4 here which is the most
principled Approach at game space and
it's night and after 92 I play Knight to
C6 and after D3 uh White is getting kind
of a king's Indian structure but as
black I'm very happy to be getting the
early space Advantage I play E5 and
after Bishop E2 Bishop E7 castling my
next move is basically the final move of
my preparation is Pawn to H5
and we can see based on the times I have
a little bit more time than I started
with given that there was a 30 second
increment and H5 is a really nice idea
because it puts white Under immediate
pressure given that H4 is now
um a positional threat to just gain more
space on the king side
and my opponent thought for a while here
and ended up playing the move Pawn to H3
now I did check at least briefly in the
database this morning and I was aware of
one game between prognananda and
andraken two very strong Grand Masters
in that game I believe it went H4 and I
was gonna play either Knight H6 or
Knight F6 I knew that these are the the
two moves that the engine prefers for
black
but after H3 I was on my own but I knew
that the engine still gives like a
significant Plus for black if we turn on
the engine I'm pretty sure it gives like
plus
um or minus 0.7 minus 0.8 in box favor
uh actually more uh minus 1.3 so I was
aware that the position is good for
black but of course it's still very much
of a fight from this position and here I
opted for Bishop E6 which I think is the
most flexible move very often the bishop
is just happy in the center aiming at
the king side and the queen side and it
aims to set up Queen to D7 creating the
battery against the H3 Pawn so white is
already under a little bit of pressure a
bit cramped for space given that all the
minor pieces are still on the board
and my opponent played a very typical
move for a king's Indian setup is Knight
to E1 and even though this move looks
very passive at first it does aim to
play F4 and expand on the king side
and I was expecting either 91 or Knight
D2 and I basically had the same plan in
mind that I would play Queen D7 and
after King H2 I went for the move Pawn
to H4 and this approach was basically
meant as prophylaxis against White's F4
idea because now white basically has no
time to get in this Pawn break if we
look at F4 here I think this is just a
huge blunder because after takes with
check whatever takes back I take on H3
and White's King side is crumbling
so White's now in a spot where I'm
threatening to take and hit the H Pawn
With The Rook as well so my opponent was
basically forced to play G4 and this was
a pretty big accomplishment especially
after the next move I played Pawn G5 and
this basically shuts down the whole King
side white never has any realistic
chance of getting this move in without
just losing a pawn and now the plan for
black is to shift Focus to the queen
side where I have more space and there's
ideas of expanding and it just seems
like a very one-sided game at this point
I do want to note that my opponent
actually offered me a draw after he
played G4 so he clearly knew that he's
on the back foot but I I declined I went
for G5 and from this position I was
really motivated to try and win so here
I actually want to go on a small tangent
because when we got to this position I
was reminded of an opening trap that I
saw many years ago and it comes from a
king's Indian defense so I'll pivot uh
just a moment
and it's a trap that a good friend of
mine showed me uh probably back in like
2009 2010 but it comes from a Mainline
King's Indian
and we're gonna see a very similar type
of structure after E5 Castle Knight C6
D5 where the board essentially gets
split in half with the pawn chains and
after Knight D7 here there's a cool
tricky line for whites that starts with
F3
and after F5 white hasn't moved G4
and I was reminded of this position
because if we look in the database let's
go to leechas database the most played
move in this position is Pawn F4 and
this is actually walking into a
strategic trap now a lot of opening
traps are very tactical but F4 is a huge
strategical blunder
and the reason why is white has a move
H4 and basically What's Happening Here
is there's no way for black to open the
king side whenever black plays H5 light
will play G5 whenever black goes for G5
like we'll play H5 and the whole King
side is basically shut down if black
tries to attack the pawn there's going
to be Knight G2 defending
and I remember this line and my friend
was saying that white is basically
strategically winning in this position
because of the king size is shut down
black has no attack and white has all
the possibilities on the queen side now
if we go back to my game a very similar
situation has happened even though white
doesn't have the pawn far down the board
the king side is is also shut down and
there's just free reign for black to
start expanding on the queen side
now I knew that this position still
takes a lot of work but I was feeling
very good especially getting such a
position after just 12 moves with the
back pieces and I knew at this point
that I'm pretty much the only one who
can play for win and let me hide the
notation and we'll go forward from here
so the next several moves were very
natural improving moves now my opponent
did start with Pawn to C4 which is an
interesting decision to try and close
down the queen side and it gives me the
option of taking the pawn but I think
this would be a good transformation for
whites because then the E3 Square
becomes available for the bishop there's
also ideas of the Knight coming into D5
so I let the C Pawn be on passant is not
forced and I improved with Pawn F6 just
ensuring that my Bishop's not tied down
to defending G5 and after F3 I just got
my pieces into the game play A6 Bishop
F1 Knight E7 la lot of natural improving
moves he plays Knight to G1 which looks
a little bit awkward at first but he is
making way for The Rook to come to the
queen side also ensuring that the bishop
has a little bit of life
and I was taking my time
um at least not going for the immediate
breakthrough I started with King F7
first and after B3 then I play B5
and now there is Pawn tension between
the B and Z pawns he plays Rook C2 I
play Rook B8 he plays Bishop D2 I play
Queen B7 and basically I'm getting ready
to either take on C4 or go for this
eventual a pawn advance and what I
really want is to open up some lines on
the queen side
so he's still waiting he plays Knight to
E2 and now I decide to play A5 which is
perhaps a little bit of a committal move
but I figure that's the main way to make
progress in this position I'm dreaming
of playing A4 and creating some
potential weakness in white structure
now he pretty quickly responded with the
move Pawnee for himself so fixing my
Pawn on A5 but the drawback with this
move is white is giving me first of all
full control of the file after takes
takes I'm controlling now the only open
file on the board and I also have full
control over the B4 Square which can be
very useful for my knight very soon now
I didn't start with Knight B4 even
though it looks attractive I figured
that that can probably just play Rook B2
and it's hard to make progress here so I
started with Rook A6 going for the
Triple up basically trying to form a gun
on the B file and then maybe later
infiltrating or eventually getting in
night before and he played the move Rook
A2 so white still basically passively
waiting and I go for Rook B6 and now he
plays Knight to C2 and with this move he
does have actually a very very clear
plan of playing Knight A3 and bringing
the Knight to B5 which I was essentially
aware of like when he played A4 I knew
that this is White's main idea in the
position and my plan to stop this was to
start with a move night B4 and when I
played this move it looks like white has
to take the Knight either with the the
Knight or the bishop because I'm hitting
the Rook on E2 I'm also hitting the
undefended pawn on B3 and after I played
this move my opponent came up with a
very strong response which I'll admit I
underestimated a little bit he played
the move Knights to A3 basically
sacrificing The Exchange on on A2 also
allowing me to take on D3 if I want
and this move came as a surprise because
of course I I'm happy to try and win
material but I realize that if white
gets the Knight to B5 it's very hard for
black to actually make progress in the
resulting position and I took a lot of
time here trying to figure out what to
do I concluded that the lines with
taking on D3 are just very very murky
it's very hard to assess the situation
where white has a potential discover its
tax against the Knights by taking either
Pawn with the bishop so I decided to
snag The Exchange on E2
and after Rook takes A2 I play Knights
to C6 so I want material and I'm still
looking to get now my other Knights to
B4 but after he plays Knight B5 I play
Knight B4
he trades on V4 we get a position where
my only source of counter play is this a
pawn which the file just became half
open for me so when I saw this position
from a distance I was thinking I can
shift over to the a file and have a lot
of potential attackers against A4 the
issue is white can just defend and my
opponent started with a move Knight C1
and now White's plan is to bring the
bishop to E2 and eventually to D1 and at
this point it's actually very hard for
black to find a plan to break through
I played Rook 8. he plays Queen C2 I
moved back with the bishop he plays
Bishop E2 and at this point
I was coming to terms that there's just
no clear plan in the position like even
though it feels like black is better and
feels like there should be some way to
play for win I took a lot of time and I
did not see anything so I played a few
more moves Rook A6 Bishop D1 Rook C8
King G2 Queen 8 King F1 Bishop d8 Queen
B3 and after Queen C6 I offered a draw
and my opponent took it and it was kind
of an anti-climactic finish to what I
thought was just a very one-sided game I
was in control this whole game but I
just didn't quite find the way to make
sufficient progress
and to my opponent's credit I think he
defended very accurately like he
basically got a fortress in the position
and he was very patient and found I
think the key idea when he needed to by
sacking The Exchange on A2 and I'll be
honest that I don't know where my
Improvement was in the game even after
checking the game like briefly with the
engine uh for a while in this later
middle game stockfish will give pretty
consistent minus two to minus three in
box favor
but it was never clear where my
breakthrough was and like even the final
position the engine will say black is
significantly better but I think that's
just because black is up the exchange
like the engine sees the material and
spits out the number but to actually
find a plan is not easy or maybe just
not possible in this position
so I think this is a super interesting
game that definitely calls for a lot
more post-mortem analysis to see if I
actually had any opportunity to crack
the queen side I'm thinking that my best
opportunity if we go back was to play
after Knight A3 it's possible that I
should have played Knight takes G3 even
though it's not the top engine move not
even within the top four moves it leads
to a lot of interesting Transformations
and perhaps it would have taken some
risk for me to play for win like Bishop
takes A5 and then Knight B2 yeah just
gets very murky but perhaps this would
have been a more practical option for
black anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
this game it was uh an opening success I
was feeling good like most of the game
until the end where I've realized I just
couldn't break through if we want to see
the engine breakdown of this game I do
have a different chapter
let's see yeah look at this I think I've
played like three or four games as
tournaments with basically a perfect
score according to leeches but
um yeah it doesn't feel perfect that I
like I was better for most of the game
and didn't actually win
but what to do hopefully some lessons to
take away
yeah I'm wrapping it up here thanks
everyone for watching I do appreciate
all the kind comments and support
throughout this tournament uh there was
one more game to go so stay tuned for
the final recap and I'll see you guys
soon